when hundreds of hunger in shades poured
from the Phantom Zone into metropolis
Superman flew into action within the
Phantom Zone he fought the assaults
horrifying mastermind aether Superman
emerged victorious but the Phantom zones
energies altered his body and fractured
his mind returning to Metropolis he
found the people he'd sworn to protect
had been transformed into hollow shades
this revelation shattered his sanity
leaving nightmare Superman to wander the
city as king among phantoms a powerful
support nightmare Superman wields
Phantom Zone energies to lock down
enemies and protect allies his passive
is possession when defeated nightmare
Superman possesses the enemy champion
who dealt the killing blow revealing
them and reducing their attack and power
armor for a few seconds
if the enemy champion is defeated while
possessed nightmare Superman is revived
with health equal to a percentage of his
possessed enemies max health phantom
collector opens a portal in summons a
phantom the Phantom flies to nightmare
Superman dealing power damage and
stealing power armor from each enemy
champion hit upon returning to nightmare
Superman power armor is granted to all
nearby allied champions based on the
amount of enemy champions hit use vortex
to create a warp of phantom energy that
reduces enemy move speed after a few
seconds
vortex collapses and pulls all enemies
towards its center dealing power damage
use the skill a second time to collapse
for Tech's room stealing power damage
based on how long the vortex was open
psiphon infuse has two functions when
used against an enemy siphon deals
strong power damage and bounces to give
to nearby allies a moderate temporary
shield when used on an ally in fuse
grants them a strong temporary shield
and then bounces to two nearby enemies
dealing moderate power damage nightmare
Superman's ultimate is condemned which
traps his enemy inside a phantom zone
prison while trapped an enemy is
temporarily unable to move and cannot
use skills condemned suppresses the
target making the duration immune to
resilience if an enemy dies while
trapped the prison explodes and reduces
the move speed of nearby enemies pay
attention to the cooldown on possession
if defeated while on cooldown nightmare
Superman will not revive phantom
collector has a long range and low
cooldown giving you a strong poke and
harass in lane against blasters phantom
collector is even better as it steals
power armor giving you a nearby allies a
brief advantage siphon infuse is great
for its versatility its damage to shield
bounds provides efficient trades with
enemy champions and its shield damage
bounds offers reliable support when in
Lane with another ally vortex is useful
in many scenarios from holding someone
under a turret or control point and
forcing them to take extra damage to
using it when launching a surprise
attack from the urban jungle or even
when helping an ally escape condemn is
best used through careful coordination
with your team if the enemy team is
trying to escape a teamfight
use condemn to single out weekend or out
of position targets if you manage to
defeat the weekend target while their
allies are nearby it will slow the rest
of the team and might open a chance for
enemy team annihilation nightmare
Superman's teleport provides additional
power damage after teleporting
this is great for blasters supports and
enforcers who like warping directly into
a teamfight when laning starting with
nailed ring and tech tide vile offers
sustain and early damage
Abin SURS lantern is core to nightmare
Superman's main role as support
providing will and some power damage
consider rushing tier 2 of Abin SURS
allowing will battery to stack up while
laning after completing tier 2 of Abin
SURS you have the choice to build for
offense or defense depending on the
needs of your team if the situation
requires offensive support Tristar Hart
and cosmic belt for high power damage
and some power penetration if you need
some defensive support too powerful
artifact choices are metallo's heart and
entropy ages more importantly the bonus
will from these artifacts enhances
siphon infuse making your shields more
effective inflict a storm of suffering
and sorrow as the phantom King nightmare
Superman
you